there's a fair point
so are you like a superhero like the
gold devil
I'm a daredevil
I like it I love it
I love how they could bring in the music
it's I mean which which is better
between this
every time there's a daredevil crossover
or a defender's Universe grasshopper
look at that dude
yes like I'm all about it please
Nostalgia I love it member berries oh my
god
oh wait let's go
get them burn it down Daredevil oh I
hope you have health insurance oh I
don't want to run into this guy in a
hallway ever
let's go
I miss this so much
I need this in my life hey oh just talk
out and tear it up this is so awesome
oh man oh man you know F off Cersei
nicorice this is way better oh oh who's
doing the walking shame
is next episode the finale come on let's
go I find this all very unsettling
season
this is the big twist isn't it but the
question is is it the kind of twist
that's like oh there's another Hulk but
this one's red or like I'm getting
fridge
she read that article she read that man
fights with metal quads article she's
and that was her she's a paralegal
welcome back to new rock stars She-Hulk
episode 8 gives its most impatient fans
everything they could have wanted
Daredevil Matt Murdoch including Netflix
theme music Daredevil back in the
hallway LeapFrog
oh sorry we got the horniest Marvel
Disney plus has gotten yet uh some
little confirmations that sokovia courts
were repealed and wakanda vibranium is
loose we got a wink to Red Hulk and
Wolverine the intelligencia humiliating
gin and bringing out her her angry side
Daredevil and cheese
this is inside Marvel new rock stars
She-Hulk after show I'm Eric Voss with
me is Mt how you doing Mt I'm doing good
man it's today's the day today is
frogmas for me I've got my boy Eugene
patilio hashtag free Eugene hashtag
Eugene did nothing wrong absolutely was
Flawless uh morally neutral even in this
episode
um just so good I love him Brandon did
an amazing job like Brandon Stanley he
was great fantastic asleep bro
um now you may be wondering where
Jessica Clemens is unfortunately she had
a pet related emergency this morning uh
thoughts and prayers
it's not it's not that serious I don't
think it's that serious but also
remember that we can't talk with her for
this episode she's still gonna be doing
the breakdown though that will be coming
out tomorrow and you know that Easter
egg breakdown's gonna be lit because so
much happened in this episode to hear
her thoughts about all of this but let's
let's react to this episode and all the
crazy stuff that happened in it the
episode begins with Jane patillio
LeapFrog he comes to Jen wanting to sue
Luke Jacobson for his suit Catching Fire
when he tried to like stop these guys
from stealing cute Lids or oleds which a
fascinating debate especially with the
episode of Game of House of the Dragon
this week I think a lot of people were
like which TV has the better um you know
um a contrast on the screen because we
all need some high contrast to oleds and
HBO assumes all of us have high contrast
Outlets apparently if they release their
episodes looking like this
um but um we find out that Eugene's
father I assume Vincent patilio is a
major client of GLK and H uh which is
interesting this episode doesn't dig
that much into the patilio family
history but I just found all that
interesting so Holloway makes Jen take
on the case and this drains her
relationship with Luke he's like I'm not
gonna design any more suits for you but
remember Jen still has that other hang
up bag that she hasn't gotten into yet
and during the trial Luke's lawyer is
Matt Murdoch who Jin introduces with the
hilarious slide of who's this [ __ ]
she say that about a blind lawyer it's
so funny
he's like hey she's competition so who's
this [ __ ] I don't give a damn he's
like I gotta take him down and uh as
Matt was in Spider-Man no way home he's
just one hell of a lawyer he's dropping
legally he's left and right getting
Jen's request to reveal Luke's Client
List denied uh he also mentions that the
sokovia Accords have been repealed which
you know might have seemed obvious to
some because plenty of superheroes have
been walking around at phase four but
this is huge huge implications for the
MCU it's specifically Matt's life in the
MCU uh we're gonna talk more on that
later uh but Matt gets Eugene to admit
that he used freaking jet fuel in a suit
so the judge dismisses the case now Jen
or Matt buys Jen and Appletini and he
tells her Jen Walters can use the law to
help people when Society fails them and
She-Hulk can help people when the law
fails them uh this scene is
sopping with sexual tension I even think
that Apple TD the fact that the Cherry
floats all the way to the bottom of the
green I mean that red mixed in with the
green there I I can't help but read into
that the symbolism
like that that's what these uh writers
get paid for the symbolism perfect and
we have to assume that you know Matt
Murdock is a courteous lover and he took
care of business I would hope so an
unlike Batman I mean this is Marvel
we're talking about here you know what
I'm saying
I don't even say
[Music]
um
so jyn gets a text from Todd requesting
he meet her at a bar and then follows up
less than a minute later texting I was
assured that glknh was a 24 7 firm can I
call Holloway to ask if that's
inaccurate and I'm so annoyed I was so I
hate to admit it I have sent texts like
this before what I've just been up in a
mood like um excuse me I was told uh you
know
but like Todd himself he's just so like
creepy of a dude that's just like you
know that he wants something that's not
business related what a freaking group
absolutely uh so she meets him at this
bar he says that he bought a wakandan
spear at auction for one Milli and a
million dollars for a whole wakanan
spear that's a hell of a deal vibrating
is supposed to go for like ten thousand
dollars per gram of it uh and that's a
lot of grams in that spear wait did I do
the math right Ethan wait ten thousand I
don't know how many grams that spear is
I just think a million dollars for a
whole fashioned wakandan spear is is
really really low like I feel like if
that were at the auction that Hawkeye
was at that would have gone for like 10
times that 100 but he says what
continents are suing for it back uh and
he does the just the cringiest will kind
of forever salute
it was so uncomfortable for me and for
Jeff
but it does like set up some interesting
questions for what we're going to see in
black panther wakanda forever it seems
like very much a movie that's fought uh
a war that's waged over vibranium and
how the whole world is trying to plunder
those resources you have two different
kingdoms with uh their natural supplies
of vibranium and everyone's trying to
get get at them uh so I feel like this
is this may be tied in with that right
maybe like wakanda is like reclaiming
any of the vibrating that's out there uh
I mean we know they've always felt this
way like they've always felt like that's
that's one uh good quality that
killmonger left them with that like
trying to reclaim the colonists
items you know but uh so Jen pushes Todd
away
um and Daredevil is trying to catch
Eugene on his sports car and I might I
might have missed this do we ever figure
out exactly why Daredevil is trying to
get at Eugene has has he already found
out at this point that Eugene is
kidnapped Luke and that's why he's
trying to get to him yeah I think so
because um like she all goes like yo
like why didn't you mention that before
we fought he was like well you just
started punching me man like so I think
okay but you know this is just a fun
thing in the MCU superheroes when they
look at each other they just like start
Alpha in each other immediately like we
there's no time to talk we're gonna
fight this is just like the classic
thing it's like it's like WWE it's like
people are just gonna naturally start
swinging at each other it's what the
people want to see
uh so we get this great fight between
them Jen uses Oliver's skills this is uh
she like punches the the roof of the
garage so that it crumbles uh she uses
the Thunderclap she takes Matt down she
unmasks that Matt introduces himself as
Daredevil set to John pasano's uh iconic
music from the perfect series and yeah
there's a Rogers the musical billboard
behind them so I guess that show is
coming to LA and I you know when I was
at d23 they did an La Cast performance
of uh I can do this all day and I loved
it everyone was great but my boy uh Nico
de Jesus was not playing Ant-Man in it
and it it broke my heart the guy that
got to play it man really good dancer
but he's no
do they not understand that what are
they doing hey this is the thing with
torco this is why they do tour codes you
got to give other people a chance to
take the role but they're not the
original cast and you know Nico's on the
original cast recording so he's exactly
he's Immortal that's he's in the MCU
that's that's what matters
um so Jen and Matt arrive to Eugene's
Lair the lily pad and empty and I were
talking about this before we started
recording this is insane this is like we
started to see [ __ ] like this in Hawkeye
where they had this weird Toy Factory
that they were hanging out in this is a
straight up like a 90s Batman the super
villain where it's like themed they got
in like stand-up boxes of Frogger that
they're playing like it's it's just wild
anything frog related they filled it in
there and there's like straight up goons
instead of inchman it's like the dudes
were dressed up like frogs like that
would have been even better it's like
yeah weird little frog or at least like
tadpoles that's what they were talking
about right it's like they even
referenced that like or it could be baby
frogs or tadpoles that's the same thing
dude
um yeah but I don't know if that would
make them that would make them henchmen
not goons I think at the end of the day
because then they wouldn't just be doing
it for the paycheck they'd be doing it
because they believe in the they want to
wear their uniforms but um so um yeah
Luke is in here
um Eugene is like forcing him to make
these this new super gear and um Up on
the Roof Jen and Matt debate the
difference between goons and henchmen uh
Matt takes down many of these goons and
just like the neatest Halloween fight I
loved this
um not everything needs to be a one take
that's unbroken but I think the action
itself was just pretty great I loved how
he used the surfaces to Ricochet I loved
how he's doing his mid-air rolls and
flips that's all I need that's all I
want from Barry man and he delivered
Studios knows what they're doing that's
all I needed to see and like they are
clearly they clearly have a a good range
on Daredevil absolutely I think they
fully understand what fans love about
Charlie Cox's take on the character and
they have just completely stuck The
Landing with with the way they brought
him into the MCU first in Spider-Man no
way home introducing him as a lawyer uh
first and in this episode just showing
how great he is as a lawyer uh and then
and then showing his vigilante skills
and his combat skills and like they even
bring in the music like they they want
this to be the Daredevil that we know
and love from the Netflix shows uh and
there's so many good things to say about
they could have made so many different
choices with the way they brought them
in and they just made all the right ones
so I'm right so pleased to see that
um so Jen Smashes in she uh she beats up
a lot of the other guys they're able to
rescue Luke Matt says he's headed back
to New York the next day he offers to
take Jen out on a date the next time
they see each other but Jen's like let's
get those fries to go and she takes that
devil Down to Georgia leaving our man
grinning ear to ear as he does the
walkashame the next morning the things
he will have to confess to Father
Lantern when he gets back oh forgive me
Father I clapped those green cheeks
forgive me Father
ly in terms like
[Laughter]
I'm gonna need more details than that my
son
and Matt's just like no I don't think I
will
just cut to him and Jen pounding to it's
been a long long time oh my god
um
just say bed smashed smash the splinters
um so at this point the episode gets
really interesting Jen addresses the
audience uh she's assuming the episode
should be over and I looked at the time
at that point it's like 24 minutes this
is normally when we cut to credits and I
just love the awareness there uh but she
realizes it's the penultimate episode so
it's time for attacked on Cliffhanger
twist Jen wonders if it'll be red Hulk
or if she'll get fridged and I don't
know about umt but I felt like I know
Jen has broken the fourth wall several
times on this series this moment felt
supremely unsettling to me yeah like
just like her confusion about a reality
right now she wasn't this is the first
time she's broken the fourth wall
without just mild concern or judgment or
just laughing something off she's like
what is happening right now I felt like
Wanda Vision where you know Wanda was
like I don't understand stand if I'm in
a TV show like I felt like it's the ring
and the character's gonna pop out of the
screen and slap me yeah like it's it's
that loss of control feeling because
like you know in one Division and we
knew that Wanda was in control and then
like she lost control and then he or she
uh we she looks like this is my show and
like she's always been in control but
like she's like and she's literally like
I I don't know why you guys are still
here like you guys usually go when I
need you to go so like this is I feel
like God is watching us like the
Watchers watching us at this really
pivotal moment in my life like what's
gonna happen yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely and I think this was such a
good like tonal adjustment and and at
the end of the episode because the
episode has been so much fun and just a
good vibes like classic MCU two
superheroes coming together funny
trading quips fighting a little bit then
working together having some great
collaboration and then hooking up like
it had that great chemistry that uh
that's always been the best part of the
MCU so we needed an adjustment there to
like you know make us worry suddenly and
I think Jen did a good job saying like
something bad's about to happen
um and this was like really
uncomfortable uh I don't know just
living in the living room with her for a
moment it felt like the the fleabag
moment where like Andrew Scott turns
around and and it freaks us out like
right sometimes it's breaking the fourth
wall can just like really get under your
skin but you're totally right empty it
it's the loss of control it's what it's
all about and it's it's really good that
they did that because that's what this
finale scene is all about we see Jen oh
by the way yeah Nikki totally
impersonates Wolverine there she just
snitched sound which I just love like
it's so fun I I I'm wondering how
prevalent Wolverine is in this universe
like what has he done like it seems like
people know that he's out there and like
people are aware that he exists to some
degree yeah it's it's hard to know how
how a self-aware Nikki is in on this
show I think a lot of the Easter eggs in
the show are just being plugged in just
as like not the fans as opposed to in
the universe into connectivity like this
kind of like Indiana Jones Easter eggs
showing up in Star Wars I don't think
they're right to tell us that like
Indiana Jones existed in carbonated
somewhere I think it's just kind of like
a nod to the fans at that point but I
don't know Nikki's also uh breaking the
fourth wall to look at the camera with
her eye rolls so I don't know what what
she's all about there's all kinds of fun
conspiracy theories about Nikki
um
so on to this Gala we found out that Jen
receives an award but so does like
several other female lawyers here at
Mallory book
um it like this ridiculous this totally
ridiculous ceremony where like they have
this guy saying how does it feel to be a
female lawyer I mean if this were really
I think the organization is real I don't
know if the whole event is a sham
because the event just feels kind of
like the hell is this event yeah like
it's it felt like a pageant man it just
felt like hey like here's a bunch of
ladies that are lawyers and like you
know we're just gonna give them all
Awards because I I feel like you know
whoever was in charge didn't really care
about the event it's just like hey let's
just put let's recognize all these
ladies rather than you know ex picking
one that like it was exemplary they're
just like hey whatever ladies are smart
let's just do this event and like it
just shows them like you know they
didn't really put much care in my
opinion for sure for sure I think it is
a commentary on how a lot of these
events are like we've never done one of
these before or every past year and
we've nominated a man for this so we
need to do one for the women and then
like celebrate rate all the women who we
overlooked in previous years and then
that feels kind of like an insult as
well I get that it just feels like that
the fact that they would have that guy
on stage asking that question you would
think like even if the event were set up
to like awkwardly celebrate them they
wouldn't have that like Mario Lopez dude
on stage who's like making them you know
asking them stupid questions but I I
don't know we can look into the
conspiracy of that because like how long
it takes uh Nikki to get them to turn
off that video you would think anybody
in the control Booth would be like oh
just turn this off yeah it's a switch
but like there's some guy in the booth
who's like no he locks the door lets
them watch all of Jen's teeth uh Mt and
I were also laughing about before this
is like this video it's like it's almost
like insane the intelligence of doing
this Anonymous style but there's like
two of them one's awkwardly taller than
the other uh and they just they play now
before they get to the revenge porn
which disgusting and awful and
horrifying that they do that it's really
like they're grasping at straws to like
show they just show like her photos on
the phone her her dating profile
matchups and then like her cable bill
her bank statement and there's nothing
damning in any of his stuff like if I
were at that event I'd be like leave
this woman alone seriously this is just
the phone of a regular lady like why did
you guys do this
there's nothing nothing controversial
here I just think what's awful is the
revenge porn because it's not like it's
not like She-Hulk has ever like she has
a public dating profile like it would
have gotten out there already that she
is someone who is sexually active and is
and it's like not a trying to like uh be
this puritanical figure she has public
figure already of being someone who
hooks up with people so just to have
like this it just you just feel bad for
her I don't know I don't think anyone in
that room would look at that and be like
oh this
this except for the shitty intelligencia
dudes I think everyone would be like
okay we don't have to look at this right
now if this If This Were a real event
honoring female lawyers I don't think
anyone had that in that room other than
like Todd who's obviously part of the
intelligencia right maybe Holloway
um I just found this really weird but
obviously what it's about is it's not
really about trying to uh tarnish Jen's
reputation it's just trying to piss her
off they're trolls they're just trying
to get her to snap in that moment and I
think that's the the broader takeaway
here is that when right people when
trolls are at their worst they're not
making any valid points they're just
trying to say and do the things that are
just gonna get you to snap and that's
what they feed on is is your response to
it yeah and your your meltdown and
that's what happens they're successful I
think that that's a really great Point
especially considering that we're
dealing with the intelligency and like
they want we know that they want Jen's
blood but like these guys are scientists
and like they they're dealing with a
whole also just like hey how mad can we
get this woman to like maybe lose
control to see like if she's actually in
the has the reins to this uh her whole
personality because and we see her like
lose control a little bit but and like I
think that may be a hint towards things
to come in the future for her character
um but like like we were talking about
before I don't like any normal person if
they saw Like This Woman's phone get
like posted on a you know at an event
everyone would be like yeah we
understand why you destroyed the screen
that's you know pretty normal response I
would probably respond the same way if I
had your power so like I don't know why
people are freaked out it's like she's
not hurting anyone she just punched a TV
um right on TVs I guess yeah I um I and
I don't know why the like I don't know
why it's only Nikki trying to get the
video taken down I think every woman on
that stage would be like everyone like
they'd be trying to cover the screen
with their hands so they'd be like all
right everyone turn away like I
understand not all what women are allies
to each other and that's like something
that that happens there could be
competition it was just like a weird
moment it's weird how it it like you
would think that there would be
something very specific that would be
embarrassing maybe that's something
specific because we're hooking up with
Josh I get why Jen would be pissed off
I'm not saying I that they did a really
good job building that up I would just
say like there would be something really
like professionally embarrassing I guess
for a lawyer I don't know lawyers have
different standards right like uh that
is something they have like their
morality Clauses and get judged against
that I guess if you're a lawyer there's
like certain I'm overthinking it I just
like found I always find it interesting
how effective the Illumina I almost said
Illumina how effective the intelligency
is when how clearly hapless they are at
the same time like I kind of wouldn't we
often blur the lines when in the real
world when we assume conspiracy from
organizations and government entities
when we really should just assume
incompetence from them uh but in this
case it's like it's hard to imagine a
group or were you meant to be afraid of
them like legitimately afraid of them in
this universe or we meant to see them as
like a parody of something and kind of
like think they're pathetic because like
there are different moments where like
they're super effective at fooling Jen
and they have like scary scary needles
um but the other at the same time they
are also just look like internet trolls
so we don't really know yet
um I assume that would get revealed next
episode I mean maybe they're both I
assume that there's like a division of
like super smart super effective
scientists who are using this network of
like trolls to like help
to help uh accomplish their goals true
and like you know nerds can be kind of
in Sally sometimes so like maybe the
intelligence here just like you know
also just in cells like these have
intels on a team they're just like hey
let's just take down
um Jen because we don't like her so it
could be both I don't know oh absolutely
I uh and I think like one thing that I
hope comes out of this show is like we
do need to very specifically Define what
an incel is uh because I think right now
it's being used as like a blanket term
to describe lots of problematic uh toxic
male behaviors that like a toxic
masculinity is a widespread broad
problem in society with lots of
different facets and permutations and
not all of them are specifically in
cells in cells is like a specifically
scary one but I think like when you just
kind of like paint them all as in cells
you're really missing the scarier
problem when it comes toxic toxic male
masculinity is like something that can
infect even the whitest of white Knights
who the most loyal a male feminist
allies could have a bit of toxic
masculinity they could have healthy sex
lives because in some means
involuntarily celibate it means they
have this lifestyle where they don't
want to have sex with women don't want
to have sex with women because they
think that the system is rigged against
them uh so they're being forced into
this lifestyle like it's it's a very
specific thing and I think people should
do it's scary there's a scary amount of
research that's ahead of all of us but
we should all do it just so we know what
we're actually dealing with here
um anyway I love how Jen punches her own
screen self in the booty hole to destroy
the screen
she's like yeah that's exactly where she
has to punch
it's like silence is booty hole once
um and uh yeah so the whole screen comes
down everyone's scared she turns into a
true like classic Hulk that everyone's
afraid of the soldiers show up they're
ready to hit her with those uh Sonic
Cannon guns and restrainer and just it's
like this sad sad final shot where she
is like got the rubble in her hair she
looks at the camera and she's like
helpless in that moment she's like
looking at the audience being like help
like what do I do here uh and I think
such a great way to end the episode and
what what a great episode overall like I
think this is this is exactly what we
want from She-Hulk uh in this episode of
course I think nailed Daredevil's
introduction to the MCU after we saw
Matt Murdoch and no way home this is
really Daredevil uh we got the the flips
the beats the beat downs everything that
we love about the character from the
Netflix series uh they engage in the
horny hookups uh that we see a lot more
of in Marvel Comics but perhaps more
importantly Now Matt as just an All-Star
lawyer he establishes a nude legal
president see when it comes to the
sokovia courts and I think this is what
the MCU has always done really well I
think for a lot of the MC origin stories
they've been uh a bit boring at times
some of them have been amazing and great
but what makes the MCU really fun is
when those characters leave their origin
stories and join other characters and
team-ups uh either in the final acts of
their movies or in the the next movie uh
like I think Thor did not become fun
until uh the 2012 Avengers film most of
those Avengers did not become fun until
that 2012 Avengers film there it's
always uh they're always compounding
each other's Powers they always uh are
built more on their chemistry with other
characters and that promise that any of
them could show up and help each other
or fight each other at any point that's
really the The Dazzle of the Marvel
world uh compared to I would this is
just my analysis of it I'm not saying
this is true uh 100 of the time but I
think I'm more likely to watch a DC
Superhero alone going through their own
private battle whereas I want to see the
Marvel characters in a sandbox and at a
party right you know it's always weird
to me when DC Superheroes do too much
team up because I I know things like
Justice League exist I know a lot of
them team up all the time I just I I
find it more fun when they're in their
own weird dark little cave or whatever
right so but yeah the sokovia Accords uh
a big game changer and it's a very big
deal for Daredevil in particular so
that's what we're going to talk about
here but empty why don't you hit us with
that merch plug yeah guys be sure to
head on over to new rockstarsmerch.com
today to grab our latest Obsession shirt
Lady Justice inspired by She-Hulk
attorney at law the shirt is limited
edition and when you purchase it you
unlock the ability to get a custom shout
out that will appear right here on
inside Marvel so support the channel and
check out all of our awesome merch
options over at New rockstars merch.com
today yes yes yes uh now Mt let's dive
deeper into this discussion what was I
think the biggest question coming out of
this episode yeah I think the biggest
question is uh why is the sokovia chords
being repealed such a big deal for
Daredevil yeah so ever since Avengers
end game the sokovia Accords have come
up time to time in interviews with
Marvel execs and directors and
showrunners everyone's asking if the
legislation from Captain America Civil
War is still effect in the MCU phase
four since the Avengers successfully
reversed the snap into Peter Thanos with
a planet really still care about
reigning them in with this superhero
registration in phase four though if you
think about the government has really
been restrictive of superhero activities
and one division sword set up that
perimeter around Wanda they use white
Vision to try to kill her and the fact
of the Winter Soldier government forces
confiscated caps shield from John Walker
in Spider-Man no way home the dodc tried
to prosecute Peter Parker and his
friends and family and confiscated Stark
Industries Tech and Ms Marvel The dodc
Cracked down on enhanced individuals and
a black panther would kind of forever
the U.N is coming down on wakanda to
share their vibranium but now Matt
Murdock confirms that the sokovia
Accords have been repealed in the MCU
and that is a huge win for superheroes
everywhere especially ones who prefer
anonymity and some autonomy and we know
our man Matt Murdoch prefers being
superhero in that vein actually one has
to imagine that Matt Murdock himself
might have played a role in getting
these Accords appealed uh or repealed he
probably appealed and got them repealed
because he could have been filing some
legal memos on Nelson and Murdoch
letterhead imagine there's probably lots
of lawyers from around the world who are
sending in briefs and memos uh I don't
know what government agency you'd have
to appeal to probably the U.N uh but I I
feel like he might have filed some
Anonymous brief uh there could have been
a lot of more high profile public
figures who got them repealed but we
didn't see this movement it may have
just been a decision made by the U.N in
the aftermath of the blips like oh you
know we don't need to enforce this
anymore right I think it'd just be a
highly unpopular decision politically
after like The Avengers saved the the
universe for like to be like all right
now we're gonna crack down on you guys
it's like it just wouldn't be a good
movie right
um for them right absolutely like uh
it'd be one thing if like government
agencies didn't enforce it that's often
what happens when there's an unpopular
law they just stop enforcing it right
and then eventually but for it to be
fully repealed it would mean that there
would have to be some government forces
who are still enforcing it and then a
widespread social and political movement
to fully and legally repeal it uh and in
order to do that that's hard you got to
get a lot of people lined up and you
gotta make sure that like there's
significant political pressure on them
and my thinking is there might have been
some superhero who was unjustly
prosecuted now you could say that
happened to Spider-Man but no one really
remembers that right after the memory
wise so it makes us Wonder like what
superhero right now in the world would
it be like Sam Wilson Captain America
maybe did he get into some trouble did
someone else did Bucky Barnes uh because
Bucky Barnes is still Bound by the
sokovia Accords did like the world come
and rally around him did wakanda speak
out on behalf on Bucky Barnes because
like obviously they have this uh loyalty
to him uh and I think that's a theory
I'm gonna go with I'm gonna say like the
Ramona wait in front of the U.N because
we know she's uh getting in all kinds of
fights of the U.N and says this white
wolf saved all your life he shot at
least three of thanos's Troopers I saw
it I counted all the kills in the battle
event game and he he got a couple of
them so you need to show some gratitude
and reveal these stupid Accords Now Matt
uh for Matt this legally resets the MCU
into the Mercury but in some ways better
place it was before Civil War think
about the timeline here when was right
before the Battle of sokovia April 2015.
when did Daredevil premiere on Netflix
April 10 2015 three weeks before Age of
Ultron released now I know these release
dates aren't that important to the MCU
when it comes to in-universe continuity
but I think this is a signal for the
kind of tone and creative thinking in
Marvel Studios is operating on operating
under when it comes to Bringing
Daredevil into the MCU they don't want
Daredevil fighting the same Cosmic Wars
as we saw the Avengers fight in Infinity
war and end game right now uh when they
were you know they were forced to be
these weird Global celebrities and
Global fugitives no I just think for now
they want Matt Murdoch to be the guy in
New York who you know who he was when he
was there around the same time the
Avengers were in 2015. this Matt Murdock
in this episode of She-Hulk gets fully
established she's already practicing
with Nelson and Murdock he's taking on
pro bono cases he's struggling to pay
the bills he's already the Daredevil
vigilante with his uh iconography and
name decided now it's suit is different
because he's getting special suits from
Luke Jacobson but he knows his name is
terrible this is not like pre-season one
daredevil on Netflix uh he has his
batons he's got a lot of gear the thing
is it's just not exactly clear how it's
going to connect because Charlie Cox has
made it clear in interviews that
Daredevil born again will not be a
fourth season of the Netflix series it's
not going to pick up right where season
three left off however I think now by
sampling the Netflix music Marvel
Studios doesn't want to erase this
character's history no far from it I
expect Daredevil's future appearances in
the MCU and Daredevil born again will
just avoid spending too much time
referencing Matt's past in that series
like his specific battles with this and
Bullseye in the hand is experience with
Elektra and Frank Castle and anything he
did with the Defenders not to say Matt
didn't go through those things I just
think they're gonna skirt over it and
say things like Matt and Fisk had a
history and leave it at that and then
new things will happen to them in the
MCU that better defines their conflicts
more presently going forward now Mass
declaration that the sokovic Accords
have been repealed as the MC's way of
signaling their Daredevil has been
operating anonymously all this time and
can continue to do so without legal
retribution but it also sets a stage for
the debate over superhero registration
to come back in this new era of the MCU
that has mutants and other enhanced
individuals in it and we might be able
to have a proper Civil War because I
think one thing that was missing from
the Captain America Civil War movie is
the true debate over superhero
registration we got it in the First Act
and then it just kind of got away from
that and became more of a personal fight
between uh cap and Bucky and and Tony
but I think what we really need is like
a widespread debate over superhero
registration now that we have people who
are not clearly Avengers per se but just
like other people who have powers in the
MCU and I think Daredevil as a you know
truly Anonymous superhero one of the few
ones left who still covers his face I
think he's gonna have a lot to say on
that and to have like a real lawyer
potentially lawyers on opposite sides of
that Civil War just imagine like a legal
battle between Hawk and Matt Murdock uh
where She-Hulk as a public superhero is
like no I think superheroes should have
to register and Matt Murdock is having
the other argument
um do you think it's time we have like a
true Civil War series empty I honestly
feel like this is one of the main points
of She-Hulk as existence in in the MCU
because like we've been introduced to so
many heroes in this show like the MCU
feels completely different before she
the after she opened than it did before
because we know that like all these
crazy people like man Bull and and
Aguila and all these like you know just
villains and and good guys are out here
just just populating the MCU and I think
that that's purposely done so that we
can get to a Civil War II scenario
because
um it happened in the comics and like I
feel like Kevin feige really does want
to just have a just a really like a
proper Civil War like you said like it's
just like straight up like we have all
the characters now like we're just
putting all these super like we want the
a huge massive war happening
um in America
um for people fighting for their rights
to privacy and I think that you know
this is the path that we're heading on
so I wouldn't be surprised to see a
Civil War II announcement in our near
future because it'd be really fun yeah
and one thing we were talking about
before is this uh possibility that you
could format it in a different way you
have like maybe a six episode series on
Disney plus if you have different
tie-ins you have each episode it's kind
of an anthology focusing on a different
character's reaction to this legal
dispute
um you can have like spin-off series the
way that you did in the comics and then
it all culminates in a movie like a
theatrical release film
so like make it a huge event that spans
multiple titles and multiple properties
in multiple formats and make it truly uh
like drag everyone into it and I think
you can't just do Civil War in one movie
I think you can you don't even have to
call it civil war you can call it
anything else but like I think there is
so much more storytelling there and I
don't think the sokovia Accords were the
proper legal basis on which to have that
argument in Captain America Civil War
because there's so much more to talk
about there than what they didn't have
to be I honestly feel like
um now that we know that the leader is
going to be a major force in cap four I
think that like everything that has
happened to
She-Hulk and potentially Bruce in this
series have been calculated by the
leader specifically to usher in the
sokovia Accords back into the MCU
because now that we know that they're
repealed I think that there are forces
like you know Hydra
um that want that control that want that
like actual like database of everyone
that is wearing a mask so that they can
control them in um and sort of like find
them I think that this is this could be
a like like Hydro or some type of
organization working with the leader to
try to you know get these Accords by
using She-Hulk and like her freaking out
and at that uh event it's like hey it's
more juice to be like we need these
people under control because these
people have superpowers and like they
they don't have one like a full control
of their power sometimes we saw them
Miss Marvel sort of like with the dodc
going after this girl with with powers
and like sort of trying to paint her as
this um threat to society I think that
um getting Society he's scared of
superhumans is what Kevin feige in
Marvel Studios are sort of like leaning
towards because then that's when it's
then it's kind of a musher
um then it's gonna Usher in uh mutant
xenophobia and like all that you know
just mutant phobia in general and uh
then then we'll see the the introduction
of the Sentinel program and all that
stuff
um so yeah baby so I just feel like this
is a really exciting time yeah I love I
love how you're thinking right now Mt
and I wonder if like they would they
call it the sokovia chords probably not
right I think like other big things have
happened in the universe since the
Battle of sokovia but I wonder if they
could call it the wakanda Accords now
like the for what's gonna happen to
wakanda in Black Panther wakanda forever
how it gets flooded maybe that fight's
gonna spill over and affect other
countries maybe they use wakanda as kind
of this like basis like oh look what
happened to wakanda when uh superheroes
tried to live in the shadows and they
tried to fight their Wars privately look
at all these innocent people who died in
the U.N may try to use that as a
predicate to announce new superhero
registrations in Phase five
um and the continents are like um please
don't use our name this way we didn't
ask you to do this
I don't know we'll see I just or they
don't have to name it after a country
either there's plenty of other like in
this in the civil war comics that has
nothing to do with the specific country
getting destroyed there's like an
incident where like a school gets blown
up and it's one of minions they could do
the West View Accords because like that
whole thing sure yeah there you go yeah
I think Westview oh yeah empty you get a
rogie that's great you get a rugby butt
um all right uh there's a lot more to
talk about this episode so we want to
get to it we want to thank Bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode while nobody
wants to be a werewolf By Night some of
us want to be a love wolf by night and
that's right this episode is also
brought to you by bluetooth confidence
can take you far in life it can also
help in the bedroom and that's where
Bluetooth comes in Bluetooth is unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
button tablets and a fraction of the
cost you can take them anytime day or
night so you can plan ahead just be
ready for whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online know if it's the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line at the pharmacy Bluetooth tablets
are made in the USA and prepared and
shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform Bluetooth can do it and
make your partner Howl at the Moon find
your inner Daredevil and find yourself a
She-Hulk and get blue 2 in the
conversation we've got a special deal
for our audience try Bluetooth free when
you use our promo code Marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring this show all
right let's talk about the
Intelligentsia uh coming out of this
episode what do you think their end game
is Mt do you think Todd might have
melted down that vibranium Sphere for
the needle or was he just bragging to
Jen right now could Todd be a red
herring every really fun if Todd was a
red herring I think that'd be really
funny
um but like I think one of those guys
that she helped picked up is straight up
Todd I think the guy she picked up at
the end was Todd in a mask because it
just sort of fit his like you know his
body profile and I think the
intelligentious end game here is age you
know to to get Shield's blood to
potentially make another more Hulks and
more like super powered beings
um for for what purpose it could be
either to just to create more chaos in
the world or just you know just have the
Hulk super soldier serum perfector so
that they can just have their own Army
of um of hug people
um but like I also just truly believe
that you know the intelligencia is
working in tandem with the leader to try
to manipulate society and like the
leader is is thinking a million steps
ahead at all times and we should all all
be wary of about the leader now that
he's in play everything that happens at
the MCU could be could be purposely
calculated by this man this man is God
levels of of smart like he can see the
future he's super op
um so yeah I think that you know we
could be seeing the intelligence of
manipulating She-Hulk
um to just sort of get these sokovia
chords back in play into sort of Gab
government entities that can be
influenced by secret Shady organizations
like Hydro or the Intelligentsia just to
have power and to have like that control
over the superhero Community
um because like if I'm a villain and I
have all like a database of all these um
superheroes I'm going to abuse that much
like um Norman Osborne Did in the Dark
Reign um Comics like when storm
Anonymous war was in charge the first
thing that this dude did was try to
access the sokovia Accords to find out
who Spider-Man was and uh Tony just
deleted it all which was super smart
with Tony
um but yeah no it's it's easy power to
abuse and I think that um people want
that power again
um because sokovia chords were a huge
huge power grab in terms of um you know
getting all these superheroes in line
um but what do you think no yeah it
makes a lot of sense Mt now it it seems
like the season is shaping up in a way
that Todd is part represents the the
Internet troll faction of the
Intelligentsia but you have like two
factions of it you have like the more
outward facing uh internet trolls who
operate whatever this website is and
Todd represents that I think it's just
like a rich jerk I think he does own the
vibranium spear but I think there is
another darker faction represented by
the leader uh and represented by other
figures in the intelligencia maybe
figures like Dr Doom and they are on a
mission to uh get as many vibranium
weapons as they can right uh so I think
that's what's gonna get introduced next
episode I don't think Todd is gonna be
the ultimate villain I think he is meant
to be kind of like a red herring like
but I don't have enough attention type
character yeah uh whereas he represents
a more nefarious entity that is very
real and very scary and that represents
the more effective maybe they even say
like we use we use all of these uh toxic
men in their postings uh as like a front
so people don't take it seriously or
people don't think we're maybe they they
think we're just this we're just like a
a 4chan a parlor or the darkest version
of these things
um but in reality they're like over way
worse and we use that as a smoke screen
so they think that's all we are but
we're actually straight up trying to
steal your blood and we're well funded
well-trained scientists funded by Victor
Von Doom or whoever else they're going
to learn a lot more about these guys at
the end of black panther wakanda forever
I think this is all part of the same
conspiracy the same operation to just
plunder the world's vibranium to have
like other weapons and other Advanced
Weaponry to control superheroes uh and I
think that makes a lot of sense that
they're trying to reenact some form the
superhero registration to like force
superheroes to to register so that
they're more controllable by government
agencies now we got this nod from Jen
when she's talking the audience is going
to be another Hulk that's red so do we
think that this is this means that we're
not going to see Red Hulk on this show I
think that you know due to the passing
of William heard I think that they'll
you know sort of like delay Red Hulk
maybe like maybe for the Thunderbolts
um just wait for that and like sort of
like figure out how to do that there but
I honestly believe that um we're gonna
see Mad Men like I've been preaching Mad
Men for weeks now and madman is another
red Hulk being in the Marvel Comics who
is the leader's brother and now that the
leader is um back in play I think that
we're gonna see madman
um face off against Hulk and like Todd
will be
um the mcu's take on madman potentially
or maybe like you know Todd is working
on behalf of madman
um but I I honestly believe that we're
gonna see that once I heard Red Hulk I
was like oh shoot is this like got a
tease for mad man I'm so excited
um but I I don't think that we're gonna
see like proper like red Hulk um
Thaddeus Ross in this season yeah but
unless um William heard shot things I
don't know um how the passing
um works yeah I don't think so yeah but
yeah I think he yeah he had cancer for a
while but you know what's interesting is
uh I it's it's weird that she said it at
all because it's I don't know how to
read it are we gonna get a moment next
episode where we do see a Hulk figure
who is red and she's gonna be like oh
it's that one and like she calls back
that line or if it's just like they
included it here just to say like we're
aware that this Theory exists but we're
not going in that direction my thinking
is based off of what the Marvel Disney
Plus shows have done in the past that
it's gonna be the latter they're gonna
go in a different direction
um I like that they brought up fridging
uh be sure to do your own research and
look up what phrygian is because it's a
it's a very very annoying Trope when
they do this and they keep doing it uh I
don't think Seahawk will do it obviously
they seem pretty aware of that uh but
it's basically where they just like
completely kill off a care character by
like just stuffing them in a fridge
somewhere and then it happens so it's
further when it happens to women this is
the mcu's second uh DC Comics reference
um after eternals yeah it's like you
know fridging is a DC Comics came from
uh you know Green Lantern we obviously
have a lot of questions about Jen's
future appearing in Daredevil born again
that seems pretty far off I think
they're going to start shooting it next
year but I think it's very likely that
she could team up with him uh but are
there any other final predictions you
want to make for next week this is the
longest Marvel Disney Plus show we've
had
um I guess no one division had nine
episodes it does feel like we're back in
one division right anyway this it's just
nice to live in a world for a while and
that's what it feels like we've been
doing on She-Hulk any final predictions
any big swings you want to take I think
that you know well hey we're gonna get
to see the leader
um at the very very very end of the
finale just like uh hey hey I'm here
I'll see you in cap four type of
scenario
um so I think that we'll see that
appearance and I think that that that we
will see Jen fight a Hulk
um in the finale and I think that Hulk
is going to be mad man
um because it just it just ties in the
theme of like family because like you
know uh Jen is Bruce's cousin and madman
is um the leader's brother and so it's
just sort of just like hey you're these
two nemesis's family members are
fighting yeah I just think that we're
going to see
um Jen just face off against the
Intelligentsia learn that Hulk King is
taught and then like Todd used Jen's
blood to Hulk out because he's so
obsessed with being a Hulk but yeah but
what do you think I'm not confident that
Todd will actually Hulk out on this show
um I do think we'll see we'll definitely
see Abomination hulking out uh movies we
know from Trailer footage I I have a lot
of questions about Abominations Therapy
Group and whether they were actually
truly nice guys I'm a little worried
because I think it's really Gonna Hurt
episode 7 looking back on it if like if
some of those guys were lying to Jen or
manipulating or exploiting Jen in some
way right because needed that to be a
genuine wholesome conversation in order
for the Thematic journey of this series
to make sense uh but um I think we will
see a Hulk Rumble in some way right uh I
think Bruce is gonna come back
um I think Bruce is coming back in this
episode uh I think Abomination and Bruce
are going to have a conversation
um I think they'll all be part of some
kind of Rumble I don't know if it'll be
Todd that Hulk stat I hope that we have
some other kind of Hulk monster I just
think it's at some point we would have
seen more to set that up it's gonna feel
like whoa this completely came out of
nowhere I think uh I think a lot of
people after next week are gonna be like
okay uh they stuck The Landing but
episode 8 was the better episode I think
we're gonna look back at as episode
eight is that high water mark of this
of the season and hey that's not a bad
thing because this was an incredible
episode of Television yeah overall and
we got we got the introduction of
LeapFrog and I think that this is very
much the beginnings for for leapfrog's
journey into the MC oh I hope so because
like I hope so we have a lot of
questions his dad is like super rich
like I have a lot of questions about GLK
and H and what they're like what their
morality ties are what their ethical
considerations are because they have a
lot of problematic clients right I think
this series will end with Jen leaving
glkh I think she's going to start her
own Law Firm I think that's going to be
like uh Jen Walters attorney at law it's
going to be that kind of thing uh or I
don't know maybe the title will just be
She-Hulk attorney at law it'll be her
own Law Firm the way that like some of
these other and with the name of the
character you know right I think it's
gonna be that I would just be surprised
if like another major MCU villain
appears on this show in the most credits
I think we may get a hint at some other
conspiracy like I think we may get
confirmation that the intelligencia is
there's another faction of it but we
won't see Tim Blake Nelson necessarily
be awesome if we did I would just I
would just be surprised right if we do
oh also one thing now that we have
LeapFrog here I honestly really want a
Marvel Studios to make a leapfrog with
the uh the guys from Abominations group
to make a Misfits TV show because all of
them would be perfect like leapfrog
porcupine all like Aguila it would just
be just so funny this is because like I
feel like they would all work very well
together I'll leave you with like my big
swing pitch and you know I'm kind of
adjusting it from what my big swing
pitch was with you and Jess where I said
that like portals would open and then
we'd have a Hulk version of like zombie
Tony Stark a Hulk version of um the
mocaps face of William Hurt version of
chapter proposal space in the vocab
version of uh of Queen Elizabeth II
space
um I don't think all those hulks are
gonna fight together I think after
watching this episode instead what's
going to happen is they're going to come
out of portals and just immediately
start each other
and they're gonna distort uh all those
um beloved people's faces into making
orgasm faces
um and they're gonna add a last one and
it's going to be that try guy who got
canceled and he's just gonna be at the
top
oh no
did I go too far
guys mentioned was uh timely very timely
reference I had to work it in we'll
leave it there for this episode of
inside Marvel Chess we missed you so
much please join us for the finale I
hope your kitty cat got cleaned up I
hope she's okay follow Mt at masterton
follow me at eavos again just as
breakdown of this episode all the Easter
eggs is coming out tomorrow so get out
for that today you're gonna get my uh
and or breakdown and you're gonna love
that because this is such a good show
also tomorrow Marvel's werewolf by night
is coming
oh my God you guys are in for a treat
it's gonna be so it's so much fun
I'm trying to move my hands in a way
that people won't be able to use this in
ways that are bad
yeah bad things it's too late there's so
plenty of plenty of ways you can do that
to me well from archive footage but yeah
wearable by night I have an Easter egg
breakdown coming out to the channel and
you're gonna love it you're gonna love
this show and I found all kinds of stuff
in there so subscribe to inside Marvel
wherever you get your podcast thank you
all so much for watching and we'll see
you next time bye-bye let's go
foreign